you
[Music]
let me see honestly I work as a data
engineer at Commodore health in the data
ingestion team and I'm gonna talk to you
about our data ingestion architecture
and in this talk first I'll say a few
words just a few words about Commodore
health as a company and then I dive into
some of the data ingestion challenges
and that we have at camuto and then
explain the architecture that we have to
tackle these challenges and after that
I'll discuss a little bit about the
things that we've learned while doing
this journey to get into that
architecture and then afterwards and
also some future developments that we
are working on at the moment and in the
end I will also talk about the ingestion
process itself and how to scale that on
top of the architecture so coming to
health is a private company founded in
2014 and our mission is to reduce the
global burden of disease to a most
actionable health care map so what
exactly does that mean we have data of
all the different aspects of the entire
healthcare system and that would be
health insurance companies doctors
hospitals clinical trials scientific
publications so there's a different a
lot of aspects in this and we are
bringing all of that data together and
have an API platform built on top of
that to draw insights at your customers
and to give a simple example what sort
of value this provides to our customers
let's say that they have a project
coming up for a clinical trial or
something like that and they need to
figure out how to best allocate their
resources how much do they need and
what's the best usage of the resources
that they could have these are kind of
questions that can be answered with the
data that we have however there are
several challenges in that for the data
ingestion and one of the thing is that
since we want to be very comprehensive
that means that we need to have all the
data and that means there's a lot of
data sources and there's also a lot of
variation in these data sources some are
public some proprietary and the sizes of
the data
there's a huge variation they can be
just megabytes at times or go into
multiple terabytes usually not really a
huge amount of data but there is a big
variation still to handle and also the
refresh rates it's not streaming data by
any means but we may have daily
refreshes for certain data sources while
others might be refreshed only on an
annual basis and what you would build to
handle these works would be very
different depending on on these
parameters and when we are integrating
new data sources what we often have is a
historical drop in the beginning that
might be much larger and after that we
have incremental additions on top of
that and the first thing in our ETL
processes obviously get this original
data extracted to our system and there
we come to the next change which is the
interfaces that we need to deal with
this data could be on SFTP or FTP
servers different cloud providers could
be AWS s3 or Google Cloud might use
api's to get the data or downloaded from
internet we even get data delivered us
on hard drives so we need to figure out
how to interface with with all of these
and once we have these original files
convert transfer to our system as they
are we do a minimal amount of
transformations just to convert these to
a park care format and that we can then
use later on and they're a big issue is
that again these various data formats
that we need to deal with we have a lot
of CSV files also we need to parse XML
files and we have more rarely SAS data
files fixed-width files and all of these
different file formats have their own
nuances that we need to somehow handle
with so it's very difficult to provide
something generalized to handle all of
the data because of these differences we
also get data in poor care for format
which might seem very nice because
parquet is what we are putting it into
but there it's actually tricky because
of the row groups and that we are
getting were so small that the
oh just reading those files was very
terrible and also of these files could
be compressed in in different kinds of
formats so the data could be encrypted
and then under the data ingestion we
also have some pre-processing steps and
- before we provide it to our internal
users and especially in cases where we
have several datasets that cover a
similar aspect of the data then we need
to define a common schema and then map
all these new all these data sources
into that common schema in a step we
call common ization so that we can
actually make some sense of the nuances
and differences in those data and
whatever we do is obviously security and
privacy considerations I mean obviously
everybody wants to keep their data
private and not let anybody else to get
access to it but when dealing with
healthcare data there are additional
requirements and compliance is that we
need to deal with so before we had a
centralized system we were still
ingesting the data but there is always
the question of priority and these are
our data engineering values of
scalability maintainability robustness
and reliability I'm sure everybody in
the audience agrees that these are great
things to go for but also there's the
rapid development which in a small
company is often requested and it's not
really that you choose one or the other
but you have to prior I like balance
these two things like what is reliable
enough and when you need to move forward
faster so often in our case we have to
emphasize moving forward fast and
provide value to our customers but the
good thing in that is that it be can you
become agile to changing requirements so
if you spend a lot of time working on
something that is perfectly engineered
but once it's done it's already obsolete
because you need to do something else
you have wasted all that effort so
moving forward and building on top of it
is a better choice but this has some
consequences these are very on a high
level but they apply to data ingestion
as well so we have very specialized
pipelines often
because especially in a case when we did
not have a data ingestion team as a team
yet so it could be different developers
doing data ingestion more or less ad hoc
basis so they build something for what
they need to get done and not something
generalized and if there are manual
operations that you only need to do
let's say every month it might be faster
to just do it manually as opposed to
automate that process and then when it's
different people working on these tools
they have different ways of doing it and
in general less reusable code so why did
we build a centralized ingestion system
those issues that I mentioned in the end
it was becoming difficult to maintain
the previous approach because onboarding
engineers to the processes was tricky
and also the manual steps were
accumulating and taking more time to
operate and then finally what pushed us
over the cliff was that we had a project
to integrate a few new data sources and
all of these would have had daily
operations on them and we really didn't
want to use those manually we wanted to
automate them and also these sources
were pretty similar to each other so it
wasn't too difficult to build something
that was at least general enough to
handle these sources and if we do it
correctly we can also in the migrated
other data sources to the same system
afterwards and why why building as
opposed to buying we wanted to be
flexible and leverage the experience
that we already had with the tools and
this was actually something that had a
big impact on the technologies that we
chose because we were already using
several of these technologies and we
were looking at them and thinking that
these actually fit to what we need to
accomplish it is not a bad compromise to
use them these are tools that are
suitable for it and we already have they
seen like this knowledge of how to use
them so it's a low-hanging fruit to use
them for this purpose and this provides
us flexibility to also reuse whatever we
had already already built using these
tools what codes we would have
so finally getting to the architecture
itself what did we actually build so on
a high level we're using air flow to
organize the workflows and an schedule
schedule them and also provide alerting
that's obviously something you need if
you're automating workloads you want to
get alerts if something goes wrong so
that you can react to that and we are
using spark to distribute the processing
and both the spark and air flow
components are running in containers
managed by kubernetes and the
infrastructure is running on AWS we're
using a easy two instances as the
machines and then saving data to s3 air
flow is actually very central component
in the system we have a lot of good
functionality out of it we really like
the fact that we can organize the
workflows into that using Python code we
had Python coders in the team a muslim
team was coding in python and we want to
have it in a code we were earlier using
some tools that would have more UI based
approaches and we really would rather
have things in code and also airflow
provides hooks that are useful for this
issue that we have of having several
different kinds of sources we need to
interface so now these hooks SFTP who s3
who can sew on allows us an easier
interface with these sources and another
good thing to simplify our process was
the operators and for example in this
example tag that I'm showing here we are
using SFTP to s3 operator to do the data
transfer from external SFTP
to our s3 and this is something that
repeats over and over again in our data
pipelines so now that we have this
operator we just configure that operator
and it will accomplish the same task in
several tags then air-flow provides
alerting on success and failure of the
task straight our little box that was
very useful for us and also high level
monitoring so we see and the statuses of
the tags if they are running if there
are failures if there are successes so
at least certain level of monitoring is
provided immediately and with their flow
we
parallelized the execution of the tax
and tasks some of the negative sights
though as useful as these hoops and
operators are for us they did not really
work out of the box for us we had to
figure out how to customize them to our
purposes especially in terms of passing
credentials to access different
resources for example encryption keys on
s3 and that sort of things so we had to
work on those before we could actually
get them working as we want it to then
spark we use that for the transformation
and pre-processing steps in our pipeline
and spark is already pretty mature tool
so we found it to be very reliable what
we are doing because our processing is
really bread and by the workforce park
the data amounts are not super huge and
we are not doing anything crazy here we
are joining tables filtering data doing
some small changes so this is something
that is extremely simple for a spark to
handle and and also it provides Python
and Scala API because we have both
button Escala coders in the team so that
is also being very useful for us perhaps
the one issue that we've had is the
performance tuning it is much easier to
write code that does functionally what
you want to do then then actually do it
in a performant manner and finding that
information is a little bit trickier as
well and so that's the part where it
could be easier to do and then here we
see the different layers of this
infrastructure and this is actually very
important part of the architecture is
the interaction between these layers so
at the bottom we have the AWS layer
where we have the ec2 instances which
are then registered as notes with the
kubernetes master to provide the
resources to the kubernetes cluster and
on the other hand there's part master
airflow components like scheduler and
vpy that are running in containers in
ports that secure in this context for
environment to run these containers and
these ports are then landing on these
nodes to execute them
besides managing all of this kubernetes
provides us very nice features for
example the isolation of environments
into namespaces we can have one cluster
having both dev and test environment
running and they are in their own silos
in the namespaces but still use the same
cluster that's very convenient and on
top of that we use node selectors to
allocate resources so the instances that
we have are connected to auto scaling
groups on AWS aSG's and all the
instances related to an ast when they
are registered as a node they have a
label on them and we use those labels to
guide the pods to land on these specific
nodes and this allows us to scale these
resources for specific use cases so if
I'm scaling my ast up and get those
nodes I know that it only my pods are
landing on those so I get those
resources for myself and no one else is
going to take those and this is useful
when you have several several users in
the same in the same cluster the issues
with kubernetes though occasionally
we've had some stability issues
especially networking issues where we
have not been able to connect to the
connect to the cluster properly or or
DNS resolution inside the cluster has
been problematic and and these are
something that are pretty serious
considerations when they happen cuz it
has a big impact on our operations and
one when these have happened we found
them also a little bit difficult to
troubleshoot finding the information
what exactly is going wrong is not very
straightforward so this is now a list of
thing if I cherry-pick all the positive
things of the past slides that I got I
get a list of very nice things I could
say that yes we got this perfect system
we crushed it if I was a Salesman I
would leave it right here lucky for you
I'm more honest than that so the devil
is in the detail so let's look a look a
little bit on what sort of issues and we
have had and limitations with this
architecture what we have learned while
working on this this is one of the
limitations we have in our workflows we
have big spike
in what we need to process and there is
the problem that even if we could scale
up the cluster and it could handle these
workloads but if you would keep it
scaled up that much that would be
extremely wasteful because we would only
need all those resources for a short
amount of time most of the time much
less resources would be enough we can
scale it manually and it's not too
awkward we will scale up the auto
scaling group to get the nodes and then
scale the replication controller to get
the pots but in that situation it is
still a manual task to do and the
problems come when we are trying to
scale down because the information on
these different layers is not past
perfectly so for example if we have
spark workers and most of them are not
doing anything but there are executors
running on some of them if we now scale
down the replication controller for the
parts so that we are terminating some of
them kubernetes layer does not know
which one of those workers are actually
having executors running on them so we
could lose the the ones that we actually
would like to keep on running so as a
result we are currently running the big
workloads on separate clusters we have
scripts to bring up a cluster for that
specific purpose we run the big workload
and take it down those big workload
doesn't happen too often so it is not
too awkward to do but they distill a
manual operations that we are not happy
with another issue to stay aware of when
we have been doing this scaling up and
down and seeing how things go we noticed
that we might end up in a situation
where two spark worker pods were landing
on a same note and the reason of
existence for a spark worker is to have
resources to report to the master that's
what it does so in our case both of
these part workers see all the resources
on that machine and report it to the
master so now the master thinks that it
has twice as much resources than what it
actually does so we obviously don't want
that to be happening and people this
does provide port anti affinities that
can be used to prevent this from
happening so that two workers will not
land on the same node
and then the exciting part how are we
going to solve this problem what are we
gonna do in the future and this is what
we are currently moving towards is using
spark directly on kubernetes we could
read off the master and the workers all
together and we will just have the spark
applications talk directly to the
kubernetes master hey these are the
executors that I need and then this
executors are are running on containers
and have their own pots and another good
thing with this approach is that now
when these executors are created if
there are not enough resources for those
pots to land on the notes the we can use
kubernetes autoscaler to recognize that
and now scale up the ASG to get those
nodes and for the executors to land and
after they are finished with their job
they will be terminated and the
autoscaler will again recognize this and
will scale down those machines as well
from taking resources another problem
that we have or limitation in the system
is with the air flow scheduler we are
running the scheduler as a using local
executor which means that all the tasks
that are being executed are executed a
sub process of the scheduler so now if
we have parallel tasks we could have
several SPARC applications and some file
transfer going on all of these are
executed in the same container on that
same node using the same resources in
which case in order to scale that we
just need to get a bigger machine to run
that scheduler own so that's not a very
good way to scale those resources but
even bigger issue is that it becomes a
single point of failure if the scheduler
goes down something happens to that pod
all the tasks that were running will
fail and in general we have the
self-healing in place so now when the
because of the replication controller we
have on kubernetes when the pod goes
down the scheduler part goes down a new
one is created and so the scheduler
comes back up and if the tasks failed
properly they have market to the air
database as a failure and they can be
retried so we can just continue business
as usual and in most times it works but
there are issues with the self-healing
and one of them is the possible
inconsistencies in the airflow database
if the scheduler died ungracefully those
tasks might not have updated their
status to the database they might still
seem there as a running state even
though they are not running and
obviously then they are not refried and
will not be able to to finish and also
if this task were depending on a local
file now that the port is gone or even
the instance have rebooted you have
might lost the file that you were
depending on and in this case again the
task will always be failing and then
finally for a long-running service such
as the scheduler there could be logs
temporary files that are accumulating on
the disk and at after some point you run
out of disk and due to disk oppressor
your part gets evicted from the node and
now in our setup where we are using the
node selector to guide the new part
always to land on that same note and in
this case it becomes the problem that
that pod would always get evicted
because the disk is still full and this
would cause an outage in our in our
system so having said all of these
problems with the local executors a
reasonable question would be why on
earth are you still using it and the
answer pretty much is because we can so
that's the most simple solution to start
with in the beginning we had just a
couple of data sources local executor
was perfectly fine to handle them we had
absolutely no issues there so we only
wanted to build more complexities to
handle more in a more distributed manner
once we need to do that and to be honest
I'm being a little bit surprised how
long we have been able to get away using
just a local executor but yes again the
exciting part is that we are moving away
from it to use the cuber Nettie's
executor in which case these tasks are
now executed on a separate pods and
during to isolate these processes and
again we can use the kubernetes
souther scaler to scale the resources to
do that
but finally I would like to go a little
bit beyond the infrastructure and think
about our data ingestion process in
general so if we think about what our
data ingestion team needs to accomplish
its what is our priority we are not
really in a business of building data
ingest and solutions that is just tool
for us that we need in order to meet
these other priorities which are to
deliver the data to our users fast and
obviously deliver good quality data to
them and to do that in a way that is
within our security and privacy
compliances and to do that the
bottleneck rarely is the infrastructure
we don't really spend that much time
working on this infra and improving that
we spend most of the time actually
integrating new data sources that are
then run on on top of this
infrastructure so here are some things
that we have done in order to scale and
those processes as well this again a
diagram of our ETL process this time
showing for these data sources that we
need two common eyes to bring them into
common schema to make sense of them and
there becomes the issue that when we are
integrating a new data source in the
beginning we don't really know how we
need to do that mapping we need to
figure out what are the columns in the
raw data that we need to map to our
common schema and there to help with
that process we have a data profiling
tool which automatically tries to
recognize these columns based on the
previous data that we have and also some
reg X patterns and that sort of things
so these suggestions that they provides
helps us with the combination of step
and once we have recognized some of
these columns we also run a validation
data validation on them to see if the
data looks good or if there are any
issues and if we recognize any issues
then we can communicate it with the data
source to see like hey
what's going on with this data like why
does it look like that do you have some
issue and what's going on and obviously
this is something and when we are
communicating with external parties we
want to have that iteration to happen as
fast as possible if it takes a long time
before we notice this then it we cannot
deliver the data as fast as we would
like to and another thing that we do in
this step is to look at the some kind of
assess a little bit some of the
compliance related risks for example if
we notice that there are open text
fields in the data those are much more
likely to contain private information
compared to structured fields for
example then the next step is the is the
communication itself and it's kind of
annoying it's very similar to these data
sources but we still cannot properly
automate that because all of these
sources have their own unique features
we always have to figure out what to do
with them on a case-by-case basis and so
but what we have been able to do is to
build a tool that does the combination
based on a configuration file so this
configuration file is just a JSON blob
that describes that hey these columns in
the raw data map these in the common
schema and then these other tables that
you need to join and this is how you
join them and so on it gives the
description and then the code is able to
figure out there are not too many edge
cases that we need to handle because of
the similarity so now we can have
generalized code that can actually
handle and the common ization part with
that configuration file and and the good
part in that is that we don't need to
make new code for that so then this
configuration file could be done by
someone who just understands the data
but doesn't have to be a technical
person so you don't necessarily need an
engineer to do that and then finally if
we have issues if we have bad quality
code or our in fries failing yes
engineers need to work a little bit more
to get those fixed but outside of that
if we are delivering good quality data
like the stakeholders will not care too
much about this technical nuances so at
the end we do
validation to make sure that what we are
producing out is what we would expect so
we have created data standards that for
this particular type of data source this
is what we expect and when we integrate
a new data source we will then see see
if these data sources match to that
standard and if they do not then we will
either notice that there might be
something wrong in our communication
step maybe we had a bug there and we
need to fix that or maybe it is an issue
with the underlying data in which case
we again go back to the source source to
say that wasn't to communicate what's
going on there and and if we in those
cases we also see if we can improve the
data profiling tool to handle earlier
state in earlier stages and these sort
of issues in the future and obviously
what sort of like these are the tools
that have helped us to scale these
processes that we would spend less time
on this new data sources that we are
integrating and and obviously it depends
on on your own use case like what your
process would look like what sort of
scaling you would need on those
processes but this is still something
that you should consider when you're
thinking about your data ingestion as a
whole not just an infrastructure down
the other hand the infrastructure should
be flexible that you can also create
these sort of tools that you need to
help in these processes for example
these are all running a spark as well
and running on kubernetes so we are
using the same infrastructure to run
these tools as well so to conclude this
our we have found that this architecture
with airflo spark in kubernetes
is very flexible for complex data
ingestion it has served us very well but
there's no free lunch there's a lots of
nuances with these tools we spend a lot
of time learning how these tools work
and also how they interact with each
other so there is a learning curve to
get things running smoothly with them
but the good part is that these
technologies are constantly improving
for example some of these future
developments that we are now working on
that I mentioned
these were not available at a time when
we started to build this system and they
were only introduced at later stages and
then reminder that it's not just the
infrastructure that needs to scale is
also the processes that you need to do
that's though and and you should look at
the whole picture when you're thinking
what your data ingestion needs to
encompass to make sure that you know
what are your priorities and how you are
meeting them and with that I would like
to thank you for your attention
[Applause]
so for your data profiling and data
validation is it just some data core the
operator to do the college or not yeah
so a bit more details on this on the
data validation it's pretty
straightforward because there we have
more or less exactly we know what the
data should look like so there we can
have reg X patterns or even some like
value lists that these are acceptable
values there is a limited number of
states in the United States like you can
just use a list to check if it if the
value is in one of those and on the data
profiling it's a bit more complicated
because there we don't know in the
beginning like what is super like what
what is what exactly is in this
particular column we just know that it
could be one of these columns that we
want to map it to so then we are kind of
looking into like common values that we
commonly see in our data and try to see
if it is matching with those data and
then have like a suggestion that this is
probably what the data column would be
but it is not able to give like hundred
percent certainty it still needs to be
checked by the user if it is a correct
match or not questionnaire on the
execution engine like you move from low
to Cubana tests executions right did you
see any performance gain or changes on
that on the Cuban intersection error on
the air flow yeah so this is still a
work in progress we have not I don't
have answer to you yeah
but I but it's pretty certain that the
isolation will be helpful for us like
even if the performance the performance
isn't really the biggest limitation for
us the problem is that when the
scheduler schedule report dies and
especially if it's like one of these
like stronger outages that it's not able
to self-heal and it prevents anything
from happening so that's kind of the
main concern but with this it provides
the isolation that now the scheduler is
actually just now scheduling this task
instead of having all this processing
happen so if any of those tasks fail
it's a problem for that particular dag
but not for everything and that's the
part that we are really looking forward
to and having with the system
thank you for a great talk
are there any tools that you use for
data profiling some libraries that you
could teach you could tell us more about
yeah that's that's a good question
so in the data profiling we actually
because the kind of how it started was
that there was a developer integrating a
new data source and then like these data
issues seemed coming up and it was like
well man like I I wish I had something
to deal with this and then kind of
started to on an on an ad hoc basis that
I yes I will put on some spark code to
recognize to look through these columns
and and that's kind of how we started to
build that that we then started to
generalize that and make it more like AB
and to handle more edge cases and so on
so we started from scratch and build it
in sparse so it's like in a building
house using spark yeah thank you for the
talk and I want to follow up with that
the air flow questions so in because
this year actually last year Google
release air flow a host air fro like
composer it's like one of a sir we
should have based out of an air flow
framework and I think in that in that
solution they also do like they also
around run air flow on the kuba Nadi and
I wanted to do from from familiar with
that solution how you compare using
composer versus building your own
in-house kubinashi airflow cluster yeah
that's a that's an interesting questions
and and I have not looked deeply enough
to the composer to really wide make any
comparisons so then maybe I will look
into it in the future and see like like
what I would think about it at that
stage but I haven't really looked into
it deeply enough yet
hi thank you um I'm wondering how we're
in this process do you start strictly
enforcing a schema and how do you deal
with changing the schema from your
sources on the Left yes so in when we
are extracting the files we obviously
keep them we actually keep them exactly
as they are if that is in any way
possible so and after that when we
transport them to park we keep the
scheme of the of the original format and
that can be whatever is provided to us
and and those rarely have changes in
them and if they would then we would
need to consider that in the
communication step when we are putting
this data into common schema and then
after that we keep it strictly in that
common schema and and then and for that
we have source of truth for what that
schema is what it should look like and
at times if it really need be we make
changes to that and have like a second
version of the common schema and that's
kind of a a bigger project then that if
we change the common schema we often
need to reprocess the data that we have
to backfill to meet the new schema
requirements so sometimes so we don't do
that very often we have had need to do
that like once so far and in that case
we then just reprocess the data that we
had
with the data validation tool if you
have just you know some small number of
records that that fail the validation do
you reject the whole data set and try to
fix the errors and try again or do you
have some sort of error buffer or
something that is actually an excellent
question the one that we are like
discussing and dealing with on a daily
basis that we see something a little bit
wrong but like what do we do now like
what's going on here and it can be very
tricky actually even to notice whether
it is actually wrong or or or not
because some of the data that we get
like there's so many different ways that
you could present it at first when you
see something that it doesn't match the
validation we are like like like first
we have to figure out like how did this
happen like like what's going what's
going on here is this truncated data
that that's why it looks so weird or
what's going on and really those
considerations will then decide what we
actually do with it and then if it is on
a very we usually at most we would
filter out some of the bad data if there
is very little of it if there is much
more of it then we kind of have to like
really think about what we're gonna do
with this that are we going to gonna
like kind of go back to change to see
where that problem is coming from
because we don't want to provide that
bad data to the users of the data but
that is very much on a case-by-case
basis
um have you had issues where the
structure of the data or the schema
changes drastically because of some
business need or business requirement
and how have you handled that yeah so
there's kind of two sides to that from
the business perspective it's mainly
been like that was once that where we
really had to like change our schema but
we haven't had that many times because
we started with very broad definition
that we were it I mean did they design
this they always want everything so then
we we had to really put all the pretty
much everything that we could consider
to be useful to have in the common
schema and then only afterwards when we
had like matured the the products enough
to see what actually is useful and what
is not and and which data columns are
not often filled in the in the data
sources that we have that then we
decided that okay now let's narrow it
down a little bit so we don't have those
changes too often and then on some of
the data sources that have like more
rare reverse Cadence's and there we
actually know that almost every year
they are changing the schema so we kind
of have to have to be on alert that once
that data once we get access to that
data we want to get it process as fast
as possible but we we always have to
check that the day and that the schema
what are the changes this year what do
we didn't need to do now and that's kind
of a painful process but it doesn't
happen too often so we just deal with it
when it does
you